(crowd noises)
(motorcycles roar)
(car door slams)
(rhythmic reggae playing)
(crowd laughing and talking)
- Why you so quiet, Dushane?
- I'm trying not to take
the attention from you, bro.
- Dushane!
Right?
From Summerhouse?
- Who are you?
- (mumbles), he in lives in Summerhouse.
You know the big high rise?
- Yeah.
- I knew it!
I knew it bro, I said to her.
This is my girl, Mandy.
- Hi!
- DuShane, you all right.
- I said to Mandy, "That's
the DuShane dude right there.
Look when I first saw you,
I couldn't believe it was you, you know.
Babe, this man is the actual legend.
- Legend with rum, yeah.
My cousin, Donovan.
His girlfriend, Shanae.
- So, how long you been in Jamaica?
- A while.
- Yeah? Visitin'?
- Somethin' like that.
I bet you got all kinda
things runnin' here, man.
- Ah man.
- Yeah, I bet you do.
Can I get a selfie?
Just to show my friends back home?
- Yeah, go on man.
(rhythmic reggae playing)
Hey listen, I'm gonna
go (mumbles) to someone.
Take care, yeah.
- All right. Thanks Dushane, yeah.
- I pre-charge it.
No, I chickened it.
Ready you know, we tend
to get fucked isn't it.
- Yeah.
- A sweet piece of cookie (mumbles).
The poor suffers, but not ails.
'Cept on Friday. Tomorrow Friday.
Low on money (mumbles).
I went for the walking, take up the money.
Uh come on!
- It was actually fucking
real money this time, bro.
- You know, lick your finger.
(smacking)
Say lick your finger. (chuckles)
It's a lick your finger job, bro.
Hear me, I say, tomorrow (mumbles)
just makes sure it's there already.
Yo! You don't want an
opportunity accident.